al qaeda el grupo yihadista que
aterrorizó al mundo en 2001 autor de los
ataques a las torres gemelas y el
pentágono en eeuu el movimiento fue
fundado a finales de la década de 1980 y
liderado por osama bin laden un
multimillonario de origen saudita
al qaeda que en árabe significa la base
o el fundamento empezó siendo un
movimiento para apoyar a los musulmanes
que luchaban contra la unión soviética
durante la guerra de afganistán en 1989
los rusos se retiraron al qaeda se
mantuvo activo y empezó a expandirse
operando principalmente desde afganistán
sus militantes se oponen a la presencia
extranjera en tierras islámicas por lo
que eeuu se convirtió en su principal
enemigo
en 1998 atentaron contra las embajadas
de eeuu en nairobi kenia dar es salaam
en tanzania y también organizaron un
ataque suicida en el año 2000 contra un
buque de guerra estadounidense en yemen
en 2001 militantes asociados con al
qaeda protagonizaron los ataques del 11
de septiembre contra eeuu un avión de la
aerolínea american airlines impactó en
la torre norte del world trade center de
nueva york' y minutos más tarde otro
avión de united airlines se estrelló
contra la torre sur un tercer avión
chocó contra el pentágono y una cuarta
aeronave que tenía como objetivo el
capitolio cayó en una explanada en
pensilvania los aviones fueron
secuestrados por pilotos que osama
bin-laden reclutó en el año 2000 entre
ellos había estudiantes que vivían en
alemania y un ingeniero que estudió en
eeuu el grupo terrorista provocó la
muerte de casi 3.000 personas esto marcó
el inicio de la llamada guerra contra el
terror declarada por el entonces
presidente george w.bush
en octubre de 2001 miles de soldados
estadounidenses llegaron a afganistán
bajo el pretexto de que los talibanes
escondían a bin laden
el primero de mayo de 2011 el presidente
barack obama anunció que el líder de al
qaeda había muerto en un operativo
militar de sus tropas en pakistán